hi everyone I'm Stephen basil from the
Google Drive developer relations team
today I want to talk to you about a new
feature which is the integration of
gmail and drive with attachments and to
show off this feature I just want to
take a look at this email that I sent
myself and it's just a few photos that I
took on my recent vacation to Alaska and
if I click on one of these files what we
see here is this great preview
experience and it's the same preview
experience that we've had in google
drive itself for quite some time of
course can scroll through these files
and this this one here I want to do a
little bit more with so if you go down
to the bottom here you see this open
with menu and here i have a few
applications that i've already installed
I'd like Pixlr use that application a
lot i also have cafepress but if i want
to try out something else i can of
course click connect more apps and here
we see applications like picmonkey which
is another great photo editing app and i
can install that and edit with that as
well but for now I want us to stick with
Pixlr so here going to go back open with
Pixlr and in just a few seconds here
we'll see the photo open up the cool
thing is with Pixlr they didn't have to
change anything for this this is the
same Drive application that they've had
since we've had this feature in Drive
just now works with gmail so if you
built a drive application this is a
great new feature for you means a lot
more users are exposed to your
application and if you haven't yet
gotten around to building one yet you
have a lot more reasons to do so and i
hope you enjoyed this feature and i hope
it brings a lot more success to your
applications thanks